ya que sabemos calcular el estado de
oxidación de los carbonos observemos
algunas reacciones redox y recordemos
estas definiciones de química general la
oxidación involucra el incremento del
estado de oxidación mientras que la
reducción involucra la disminución del
estado de oxidación también puede
recordarlo como que la pérdida de
electrones es oxidación y la ganancia de
electrones es reducción así es que
observemos esta molécula y tratemos de
encontrar si el compuesto inicial fue
oxidado o reducido a ninguna de las dos
vamos a ver si este compuesto se oxida o
se reduce cuando se transforma en este
otro compuesto y bueno podemos empezar
observando que estos tres carbonos no se
modifican se quedan aquí tal cual
entonces tienen los mismos enlaces con
los mismos átomos y por lo tanto su
estado de oxidación no cambian
sin embargo este carbono de aquí no se
encuentra en las mismas condiciones
cierto porque aquí está el carbono tiene
un doble enlace con un oxígeno tiene un
hidrógeno y también está enlazado con
otro carbono mientras que en esta
molécula ese carbono sigue teniendo un
doble enlace con un oxígeno
con este carbono de aquí pero ahora
tiene un enlace con un grupo o h
ok entonces seguramente el estado de
oxidación de este carbono cambio y
podemos encontrar el estado de oxidación
del carbono utilizando la fórmula que
vimos en el vídeo pasado ok vamos a
empezar por aquí lo primero que hacemos
es colocar todos los electrones de estos
enlaces
y vamos a tomar en cuenta que tan
electro negativo son estos átomos el
carbono es más electrón negativo que el
hidrógeno entonces se va a quedar con
todos los electrones de este enlace por
otro lado el carbono es menos electrón
negativo que el oxígeno entonces el
oxígeno se va a quedar con todos los
electrones de este doble enlace y
llegamos a este enlace entre 2 carbono
podemos suponer que los 2 carbonos son
igual de electro negativos entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es repartir los
electrones en partes iguales aunque hay
en este enlace tenemos 2 electrones y a
cada carbono le toca uno de los
electrones y para encontrar el estado de
oxidación de este carbono no pensamos
cuántos electrones de valencia se supone
que debe de tener el carbono pues se
supone que tiene 4 electrones de
valencia y aquí en nuestra estructura de
puntos el carbono está rodeado por 3
electrones entonces le restamos
y lo que nos queda es 4 3 1 o sea que
este carbono tiene un estado de
oxidación más 1 más 1 y ahora que pasa
del lado derecho pues tenemos que poner
los electrones de cada enlace cada
enlace está conformado por 2 electrones
y otra vez nos ponemos a pensar en la
electro negatividad en esta estructura
de puntos del carbono está enlazado con
este oxígeno en lugar de con este
hidrógeno entonces como el oxígeno es
más electro negativo que el carbono
pierde los electrones de este enlace y
bueno por acá tiene un doble enlace con
un oxígeno el oxígeno es más electro
negativo entonces se queda con todos los
electrones de ese enlace y aquí tenemos
el enlace de carbono carbono y en este
enlace
otra vez dividimos los electrones a la
mitad y a cada carbono le toca un
electrón y como podemos observar aquí
este carbono está rodeado únicamente por
un electrón entonces a la hora de
calcular el estado de oxidación de este
carbono tenemos que se supone que el
carbono tiene 4 electrones de valencia y
a eso le restamos el número de
electrones de valencia que rodean al
carbono ya que estamos tomando en cuenta
la electro negatividad que como podemos
observar es únicamente 1 y 4 menos uno
nos da 3 así es que este carbono que es
este carbono tiene un estado de
oxidación de más 3 que pasó en esta
reacción este carbono pasó de tener un
estado de oxidación de más 1 a un estado
de oxidación de más 3 nunca hubo un
incremento en el estado de oxidación así
es que se trata de oxidación nuestro
compuesto inicial fue oxidado
ahora para oxidar a este compuesto
necesitamos un agente de oxidación y eso
es para que se pueda dar esta reacción y
es justo este agente de oxidación el que
se está reduciendo porque recuerda
siempre que una molécula se oxida hay
otra molécula que se reduce pero bueno
también podemos pensar en la otra
definición de oxidación sabemos que la
oxidación involucra la pérdida de
electrones nunca y eso es la oxidación y
vamos a observar esto por acá el carbono
al inicio tenía 3 electrones a su
alrededor aquí están los 3 electrones
pero cuando se en la sobre carbono con
este oxígeno
el carbono perdió estos 2 electrones en
la izquierda este carbono tenía estos
dos electrones pero los perdió entonces
ahora en lugar de tener 3 electrones
rodeándolo
únicamente tiene uno y eso provoca un
incremento en el estado de oxidación el
carbono perdió electrones y hay un
pequeño atajo que podrías utilizar aquí
en la izquierda este carbono tiene un
enlace doble con un oxígeno vamos a
dibujarlo por aquí tiene este doble
enlace que cuenta como dos enlaces y en
la derecha el carbono tiene los dos
enlaces originales más este nuevo enlace
con otro oxígeno así es que hemos
incrementado el número de enlaces con
oxígenos y eso nos dice directamente que
tenemos una oxidación aunque sin tener
que pasar por todos los estados de
oxidación de los carbonos observa
también que este carbono perdió un
enlace con un hidrógeno y sustituyó ese
enlace con otro enlace con un oxígeno
aunque entonces si tienes un incremento
en el número de enlaces con oxígeno
y se disminuye la cantidad de enlaces
con hidrógeno lo que tienes es oxidación
bueno vamos con otro ejercicio
ok
hoy vamos a hacer este ejercicio nuestro
objetivo es observar si el compuesto
inicial este compuesto ha sido oxidado o
reducido y como podemos observar
rápidamente estos tres carbonos no han
sido modificados entonces no ha cambiado
su estado de oxidación y lo mismo pasa
con este otro carbono de aquí así es que
nos queremos enfocar en este carbono de
aquí que tenemos este carbono que tiene
un enlace doble con un oxígeno y está
enlazado con un carbono hacia acá y con
otro carbono hacia acá y en el producto
de la reacción este carbono el carbono
tiene un solo enlace con el oxígeno
oxígeno y sigue enlazado con estos dos
carbonos y por supuesto no está dibujado
pero se supone que tú ya lo sabes aquí
este carbono está enlazado con un
hidrógeno
o que encontremos los estados de
oxidación del carbono empezamos por la
izquierda dibujamos los electrones que
forman los enlaces y nos ponemos a
pensar en las diferencias de electrón
negatividad entre estos átomos el
oxígeno es mucho más electro negativo
que el carbono por lo cual se va a
quedar con todos los electrones del
doble enlace por aquí vamos a suponer
que estos dos carbonos son igual de
electro negativos y entonces cada
carbono se queda con un electrón y lo
mismo pasa por aquí entonces para
encontrar el estado de oxidación del
carbono sabemos que se supone que tiene
4 electrones de valencia y como podemos
observar en este diagrama de puntos el
carbono se queda con 2 electrones a su
alrededor
entonces ponemos menos 2 si es que 4
menos dos eso es más 2
entonces en la izquierda este carbono
tiene un estado de oxidación de más 2 y
hacemos lo mismo del lado derecho aunque
hay colocamos los electrones de los
enlaces y una vez que hayamos terminado
nos ponemos a pensar en las diferencias
de electro negatividad de cada uno de
estos átomos y así podemos asignarle una
estado de oxidación a este carbono aquí
el oxígeno es más electro negativo que
el carbono por lo cual se queda con
todos los electrones y por aquí
suponemos que estos dos carbonos son
igual de electro negativos entonces se
reparten estos dos electrones lo mismo
pasó por acá y el carbono es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno entonces se
queda con todos los electrones del
enlace y ahora si podemos encontrar el
estado de oxidación de este carbono ok
sabemos que se supone que el carbono
tiene 4 electrones de valencia
en este dibujo ya que tomamos en cuenta
la electro negatividad podemos ver que
este carbono está rodeado por 1 2 3 4
electrones entonces restamos 4 y nos
queda 4 menos 40 así es que este carbono
de aquí ahora tiene un estado de
oxidación de 0 este carbono fue de un
estado de oxidación de más 2 a un estado
de oxidación de 0
eso es una disminución del estado de
oxidación por lo tanto es una reducción
en esta reacción nuestro compuesto
inicial fue reducido
aunque y entonces para que se dé esta
reacción tiene que haber un agente
reductor y es justo ese agente reductor
el que se va a oxidar porque recuerda
que si un compuesto es reducido hay otro
compuesto que tiene que ser oxidado y
también podemos ver la otra definición
de reducción que es que la ganancia de
electrones es reducción ok si nos
ponemos a observar por aquí los
electrones que ganó el carbono en esta
reacción son estos dos de aquí ok
aquí en la izquierda el carbono tenía un
enlace doble con un oxígeno pero aquí en
la derecha ya nada más tiene un enlace
simple con el oxígeno y este nuevo
enlace con un hidrógeno entonces el
carbono perdió un enlace con un oxígeno
y ganó un enlace con un hidrógeno el
carbono que no estos 2 electrones porque
aumentó el número de enlaces con
hidrógenos y otra forma muy sencilla
fue una oxidación o una reducción es
fijarse en la cantidad de enlaces con
oxígeno aunque como lo estábamos
haciendo en el ejemplo pasado aquí en la
izquierda tenemos dos enlaces con
oxígeno y aquí en la derecha tenemos un
solo enlace con oxígeno entonces eso es
una reducción porque disminuimos la
cantidad de enlaces con el oxígeno o
también podríamos pensarlo como que
aumentamos la cantidad de enlaces con
hidrógenos bueno ahora vamos a hacer
otro ejercicio como los que hemos hecho
tenemos aquí esta reacción y este
compuesto inicial y nuestro objetivo es
averiguar si el compuesto inicial es
oxidado o reducido en esta reacción nos
vamos a enfocar en estos dos carbonos
estos dos carbonos y vamos a empezar
dibujando lo por acá tenemos estos dos
carbonos que tienen un doble enlace y
cada uno de estos carbonos está enlazado
con otros dos carbonos
y del lado derecho tenemos los dos
carbonos pero ahora tienen un enlace
simple entre ellos el carbono de la
izquierda tiene un enlace con un
hidrógeno y el carbono de la derecha
tiene un enlace con un oxígeno y siguen
enlazados con los otros dos carbonos
cada uno y ahora así tenemos los estados
de oxidación empezamos por la izquierda
colocando todos los electrones de los
enlaces
y pensando en la diferencia de electro
negatividad de todos estos átomos
también vamos a suponer que todos estos
carbonos son igual de electro negativos
entonces a la hora de ver con quién se
quedan estos electrones los vamos a
dividir a la mitad acá y vamos a empezar
con el carbono de la izquierda este
enlace lo dividimos a la mitad
este enlace también a la mitad y
llegamos el enlace doble y cada carbono
se queda con dos electrones saquemos el
estado de oxidación de este carbono se
supone que tiene cuatro electrones de
valencia a su alrededor y en esta
estructura de puntos tomando en cuenta
la electro negatividad tiene 1 2 3 4 así
es que restamos 4 y esto es igual a cero
entonces este carbono de aquí tiene un
estado de oxidación 0 y pasa exactamente
lo mismo con este carbono de la derecha
tiene un estado de oxidación igual a 0 y
ahora vamos con el producto queremos
encontrar el estado de oxidación de
estos dos carbonos entonces ponemos por
aquí todos los electrones de los enlaces
y luego nos fijamos en las diferencias
de electro negatividad de estos átomos
vamos a empezar con el carbono de la
izquierda como estamos suponiendo que
son igual de electro negativos
todos estos carbonos entonces cada
carbono se queda con un electrón luego
el carbono es más electro negativo que
el hidrógeno entonces se queda con todos
los electrones del enlace y estos dos
carbonos se dividen los electrones a la
mitad al igual que estos dos carbonos y
listo ya podemos calcular el estado de
oxidación de este carbono aquí ok se
supone que los carbonos tienen 4
electrones de valencia y este carbono
está rodeado por 1 2 3 4 5 electrones
entonces restamos 5 y nos queda 4
5 - 1 así es que este carbono tiene un
estado de oxidación de menos 1
ahora vamos con este carbono de la
derecha aquí tenemos un empate de
electro negatividad entonces se dividen
los electrones a la mitad y lo mismo
aquí y acá pero el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el carbono entonces
se queda con todos los electrones y para
calcular el estado de oxidación de este
carbono tenemos que los carbono se
supone que tienen 4 electrones de
valencia pero aquí este carbono está
rodeado por 3 electrones 3 electrones
entonces 4 - 3 eso es más 1 así es que
este carbono tiene un estado de
oxidación más 1 y al final de cuentas
que es lo que pasó pues este carbono de
aquí empezó con un estado de oxidación 0
y después de la reacción terminó con un
estado de oxidación menos 1 entonces
hubo una disminución del estado de
oxidación así es que este carbono fue
pero qué pasa con el otro carbono el
otro carbono empieza con un estado de
oxidación de 0 y termina con un estado
de oxidación más 1 entonces hubo un
incremento en el estado de oxidación así
es que se oxidó este carbono se oxidó y
que podemos decir acerca del compuesto
inicial acá y de toda la molécula pues
en realidad no hay un cambio en el
estado de oxidación del compuesto
inicial aunque hay porque en la
izquierda estos 2 carbonos tienen un
estado de oxidación 0 y en la derecha
tenemos menos 1 y más 1 que nos da un
total de 0 ok
así es que no tenemos un cambio neto ok
no es ni oxidación ni reducción el
compuesto inicial ni se oxidó ni se
redujo no es ninguna de las dos